what's going on guys Ramone Russell's
back so that means more MLB the show 18
baseball so today we're going to be
talking about Road to the show yes we
are let me throw my rose to the show oh
yeah tons of stuff in Rosa - I know you
teased this last time to do a little bit
now we're gonna we're gonna give you the
goods fine
so first thing we remember I wrote this
show is remember how we can't I came
earlier we talked about gameplay five
pillars of baseball and Harvey worked on
all that remember all that stuff is in
rows to the show right so the first
thing about Roadshow is no more
microtransactions they're gone that's
the first thing that is something that a
lot of games need to do okay
second thing is you're not like you're
no longer that top prospect you're not
Mike Trout you're not cleaning curse all
those guys a once-in-a-generation
talents that get drafted very very high
your mid to late round pick this year
round round 15 you know round 25 you
know but it doesn't matter out what
proposals a late round draft pick on
right Dawson was a late round draft pick
it doesn't matter where you start in
life it matters where you finish finish
all right so what we've also done is
because there's no microtransactions we
completely revamped role to the show
what Steve murca dick Livingston and
everybody else on the road to show
design team wanted to do was really
spice things up and the second way to
how we've done it is you can't you can't
be 99 in every category anymore right
cuz remember how you used to play role
to the show in the past you play you get
your do you good at-bats you end up
600,000 training points after the game
and you just put them wherever you want
or I can't do that anymore all of your
training points are Auto allocated now
so we'll get to that when we get it in
game first let's talk about how role to
the show starts so the story that we're
telling is you know you're you're a late
round draft pick you're not the highly
touted guy that's who you are and that's
where you're starting but where you want
to end up is with one of these art types
so one of the biggest decisions you'll
make and wrote that shows when you first
start your career you got to choose the
type of player you want to eventually
become and we have a few options we were
an outfielder a few of these options
wouldn't be available and as as pitchers
there are types as well so let's take a
look so we got the wizard strengths is
building and speed weaknesses power and
if we look over at the attributes
we can see just do can bunt his cap for
contact right to contact left is 70 but
we go to the fielding page all green
through 99 so we can have now the
important thing to remember that max cap
that is as high as that attribute can go
right so if we see that clutch 70 that's
as high as right so if we're looking at
the wizard max cap is 70 contact now you
can supplement that with licensed
equipment and we have more licensed
equipment in MLB draw a team so let's
look at some of the differences here so
we've got bat first power corner they
look almost the same but the difference
is the power corner your max cap for
contact is 75 for bat first it's 80 but
let's check out fielding look at the
changes here for final corner fielding
and reaction we can get that real high
its flipped forearm accuracy and arm
strength for bat first so we're
infielder we want to hit bombs right
that's what is that what we want to do
that's my goal we want to get bombs and
fielding and reaction time is very
important we kind of don't need a strong
arm so let's go at power corner so the
second thing to look at is your starting
cap when we start of the mode not
necessarily gonna start right there no
we're gonna have a cap that will
eventually hit and I'll explain some
more of that when you get in game so
we're gonna choose and this is pretty
much how it rode to the show begins this
is not ready to the show right hand
start if you use a year two you're safe
right
you will still go to this screen and
pick an archetype so let's say you're
already in the majors and you've already
maxed out a lot of attributes and you
chose power corner just like we did
power corner has a speed cap of around
maybe I think like 40 or something like
that if your speed is past that
threshold over time we're gonna pull it
back down it's gonna get pulled back I
understand
alright so we're back we fast forward a
little bit we got drafted twenty fourth
round by the Detroit Tigers again you
can only be a late round traffic but it
doesn't matter cuz we're still going to
the Hall of Fame still pick number one
to still pick number one
only first two days of the MLB Draft
this players weight is finally oh and
you might have noticed something else
this new we have off the field clothing
inroads to show a huge undertaking so
shout out to everybody on our team for
all the hard work they did on all of our
off the field clothing because last year
during those meetings here everything
you've seen you would be in uniform so
we also have we have like a bus off the
field scene we have a plane so we're
going to play our first game and we'll
explain to you how you get training
points and what happens to us we know be
ready we'll let this play out I mean you
can already see from this versus last
year the updates and just kind of the
environment tuning in which I know the
office loss here pretty much just had
the desk in the chair yeah we tried to
update a little bit of anything
Oh performance gains new feature
performance games
what does performance games you ask I'm
about to show you so remember in last
year's rows to the show you played games
and you came back to the front and you
have this pool of points of training
points and you just put them wherever
you want to put them in power contact
feeling whatever that's gone what we
have now is the base gains and
performance game systems so if you want
contact left against if you want your
contact against left-handed pitchers to
go up right you've got to get base hits
against a left-handed pitchers you want
your power to go against a right-handed
pitcher gets right-handed pitching you
need to hit off doubles triples and home
runs off of right-handed pitchers poor
okay use contact swing all the time and
getting rest so everything but young via
those hits off a right-handed powerful
right-handed so this is our first at-bat
look at uniforms looking good shout out
to the character team and we've done a
lot of work on all the face textures
we've done a lot of work on the hair
we've got dredge this year I think I
actually showed you that yep we saw the
dreads in the last video we're in a
minor league stadium all of our minor
league stadiums our art team went in and
redid all of the backdrop so all of the
back that was my nice lady and they have
geometry they look a lot better I know
you guys mentioned that you've done a
lot of work with the minor league
stadiums so that that means that
where in the u.s. if I'm going see the
Greensboro Grasshoppers plane in North
Carolina or Staten Island Yankees those
have all been yes every minor league
stadium backdrop has been updated and
that's everything past the outfield wall
and that's not gonna do anything all
right
so batting clutch went down I believe my
bat eclipse went down because I believe
there was a man on base in scoring
position right so here I am field in my
position there's one out and remember so
if I make this play I'm going to get
some base gains all right and it's a
base casting BAM reaction armed accuracy
and fielding went up because I made two
correctly
so this is how all of your training
points are acquired this year and their
auto spin all right what we got here
nobody on base also for role to the show
Chris Gill and the team they've redone
all of the infield cameras for when
you're fielding so no matter what
position you're using and no matter the
situation you're always gonna have
baserunners in in the field of view so
if there's a guy on first and third
you'll never have to move the camera
around you're always yo and if you're
using a centerfielder left fielder or
right fielder that camera has been
reworked completely as well
shout out to Chris Maria who redid the
outfield camera Chris Gill this year
can't wait for you guys to see that now
did this have anything to do with the
base running mechanic you guys worked on
or is this just a general update this is
general update um you know we always
look at feedback and some of the
feedback was you know the cameras some
of the cameras when you're playing and
fielding enrolled to the show aren't
great so that's why they went in there
and updated those and you can see our
all of these guys on that lineup they're
fake they're created by our randomizer
they look so much better this year and
that's because of the updates that our
team gets all of the skin tones done
thanks to the hair and update to the
base face shapes right right all right
here we go I'm power swinging here I
like that little animation too as he was
getting up to bat I think that you spoke
about those were updated as well orders
terrible my man is using this well I
keep must be throwing Heat
got their haircut we haven't said
anything with his hair yeah he's really
bringing it he's got that haircut and
there's a new swing analysis that Lance
worked on this year you're always trying
to give you more information on what's
going on since to Owen to count on go
regular swing oh now I should get plate
vision increase everything you're doing
in game it's like it's like a double
whammy you get better at the game by
playing it and you're also making your
player better and what you should see is
your guy's gonna start to evolve based
on how you are as a player with the
control in your hands your player will
evolve as you learn more about the game
yourself nice there you go first base
hit in my career let's go and I should
get a base gains and contact right
because I regular swing got a base hit
his beard is that's a full speed replay
you know Kirby and Michael Compton and
Ross everybody on a presentation team it
was all about more dynamic commentary
dynamic storylines when you playing in
season modes and more full speed replays
we got hit ribbons now and replays which
is really cool now if you were to score
the RBI there obviously you wouldn't be
controlling that but does that count
towards any of those out oh yeah betting
clutch if you bring if you bring a run
in and it's RBI you will see a base gain
in the batting clutch at you and
yourself of a you score yes somebody
else's as well no I don't think if you
score I'm not a hundred percent certain
if you score off somebody else's all
right power swing I got a I got a man in
scoring position I'm hitting my first
one line I'm calling it it's me that's
Nick I'm called unheard of confidence
I'm coming I'm calling a backup so I'm
saying calling it back to scout my
custom batting stance which we just
created
Thanks swinging at that jump give me
them plate discipline base gains baby
yeah don't forget if you guys haven't
seen the stance customization video plus
alive
yep it's not gonna work gamespot calm in
our youtube so check it out
come on pressures on when we got to one
man - - we got to - I got to drop the
power swing gotta go back to regular
swing Oh that plate vision I mean that
plate discipline here we go all right
I'm Powell swinging there's a gun and a
power strong right into a ground ball
nothing works good banana don't see our
power swung right so you see what
happened negative gains in batting
clucks there was a man in scoring
position and I use policy and
specifically to power that matter
because I use the power swing it is
break contact and we've been contacted
yep okay bases loaded this is a big one
yes sir so another new thing that you
saw when that ball was put in play you
see time slowed down for just a few
seconds so what Chris Gayle found on
doing play testing last year was there
were a lot of balls hidden played when
you were enrolled to the show in the
infield that you literally don't have
the human reaction time to make those
plays right so now on some of those
balls we slow the time down a little bit
to give you a better jump if you don't
like it you can turn it off turn it off
all right so I got a double this is
double play here I'm gonna tape this
myself oh no I'm not that's a tough one
that's a tough one it's not I also
noticed I don't know I don't know where
is this new or not not sure if I'm
viewers in here but the controller is
actually talking to Ramon saying 1 & 2
was that yeah so that's a feature that's
a feature deck I think you might have
Turner oh that's the picture that Kirby
added last year do you before and wrote
to the show where you can hear your
teammates yells and chants that's her I
have it turned off so I never noticed it
until I was like what is he talking it's
sort of - Oh almost got there
Oh God got him all right they held him
up I almost made that play now you won't
get negative points or something like
that
that's a tough play no not tough wait
didn't get any negative points all right
here we go oh here we go power swing no
absolute discipline I like that we saw
the transition to from kind of an
evening games in the night as well see
that kind of nighttime atmosphere yeah
we have full day night transitions if
you play a long enough game the Sun will
rise and come back up oh no what yep
[Music]
look early on that swing analysis says I
was early but I was on that I'm waiting
to see the first person that's gonna
play oh okay that's a double that is not
a double that is a double nice
all right so pencil versus already got
it got a double with a power swing so my
Paula versus right right what up all
right here we go Paula swing you need 10
tied it up I'm waiting to see the first
the first person stream the game he's
gonna have a game go long enough that
said that like pitch out and I think you
could hear some of the commentary you
know Mark DeRosa joining us our
three-man booth this year so that is
that was the commentary update that you
teased that was yeah that was one of the
big commentary updates oh did you get
them I didn't get them
yeah Mark DeRosa joins the booth again
commentaries about dynamic storylines
what's going on we got new base layer
for crowd audio curbing the guys work
really hard this year oh good
all right he's good
now do you have any of the special and
like custom gear or I love it the helmet
came off and do you have any of the
special like year that's gonna haven't
unlocked in them here yet but when the
game comes up on March 27th or the 23rd
early access you most definitely can get
you some licensed equipment all right
here we go - but these again are not
involved with my trip microtransactions
they're in car packs and if you and if
you are about the game last year you
still do our lower tier award bonus so
you'll get a gold
starter pack with a few items and some
of those items are equipment you know
dropping is he going yes guess that
Barbie yeah so I should get bad and
clutch and power versus left nice oh we
won that game yeah
good team good teamwork y'all good
teamwork that was good I mean that was
you that was your good teamwork
so we're gonna go back to the clubhouse
so we can see what happened and so again
remember if we were playing MLB just row
17 we would have ended up with a
arbitrary number of training points to
put wherever we want right that is gone
so here is the so here's the base gain
screen so this screen basically sums up
everything that just happened so what
we're looking at here we are looking
inside one attribute point and that's
very important like we're looking at 35
to 36 right this is what we're looking
at we're looking inside an attribute
point and we're not we're not doing too
bad our batting clutch went down because
I think we out of the what four or five
opportunities that we have I think we
only came through on one of those that's
why batting clutch went down another new
feature is the call up track so as you
get closer to getting caught up you'll
see that move so it gives you a better
idea of when you'll get caught up so
random yeah like you you have a pretty
good idea of when you're gonna get
caught up and here is your complete
attribute breakdown no change that's
always gonna say you're not dragging
anything back and forth this oh no it's
it's Oh everything's Auto spin it is
it's a college man
so there are no training points for you
to put anywhere none whatsoever
everything is essentially your coming
here to this screen to assess how did
that game go where ye where have I
improved where I still need to improve
what went down right so you end if you
remember when we chose this archetype we
had a max cap of I believe 99 power and
we had a right húrin cap of power so
let's talk about that a little bit so
we're gonna go back these are those
numbers on the right hand side we're not
the cap numbers right there so just so
this is green you want to look at so our
as we see our max cap is 99 our power
our max cap on contact is 75 so if you
see here we have something that's called
the current cap our current cap is 50 so
when we get this contact right up to 50
if we just keep playing those bass games
have pretty much wasted because we've
reached our current cap so we've hit
those obviously the next question is
well Ramon how do you extend that cap
we're going to show you right now cool
go to calendar and we're gonna sim about
a month so there are two ways to make
your player better enroll to the show
this year the first is bass games
performance games which you do in real
time in the game which we just saw this
should be the second way all right and
so you see our hitting coaches talking
to us what is he talking to us about
he's talking to us about focused
training so focus training it up there's
another brand new feature this year
you're gonna get around 25 of these per
year and you'll get run one really
awesome one in the off season of every
year but we want to tell you what's in
that one will let people be surprised to
figure that out
so we have three choices there remember
whatever choice I choose I'm not gonna
be able to come back so we have a soft
talk toss drill where we can make our
contact straight up go up
so right now wait I can't read that
let's see contact versus rainy kappes 50
kappa 50 to 56 oh we could do hit your
pitch drill our plate vision go up and
our play discipline can go up all we can
do pitch recognition drill where we can
go from 40 to 46 a see some of these
we're actually going
and actually we're actually just going
up in attribute rights alright so we're
going from 40 to 46 and those ticks
that's five attribute points same thing
right here
but here remember our current contact
campus is 50 so when we eventually hit
that this is how we extend the cab focus
training is how you'll extend the cap
and you've got to pay attention because
remember there's only 25 of these and
you don't want to get to a situation
right you've reached your current cap
and maybe you made the wrong decision so
these are very very importance of risks
like do you want to continue to grind
out do I do I want to continue to get
these to go up immediately or do I want
to look for the long game and that's the
risk versus reward right that's you're
gonna have so I'm not gonna choose that
training right here I'm gonna choose
this one and you'll see the training
results and so you can see our max cap
and current cap do you physically
participate in the training or it's just
it's simply you're picking these things
you just pick an we pick the first one
as well okay all right so here's another
training session alright so this is t
drill so this is completely different
right so the last training we had the
last focused training we had an
opportunity to extend the the contact
cap this now we have an opportunity to
just extend our contract right so again
are you gonna play the long game are you
playing the short link here we have
another focus opportunity again this is
extending those attributes right now
same thing so all three of these this is
this is gangs we're gonna get right now
and so we'll choose contact again and
there's our training results all right
so this is really awesome so another new
thing that he added is so the next few
games they don't actually tell us two
times performance games and fielding
reaction and arm accuracy I'm enrolled
to the show a lot of people only like to
bet right if you sim games or if you
only choose the vet in that field you're
only gonna get about half of the of the
base games that you could have had you
played it so this is really put when
these come up maybe this is the time
where you do do fielding so you can make
up make up some lost ground and so will
stop and then if he goes in because that
two times boost is in the next five game
right you see
so right here we have a 2 x boost act
with 5 games remaining and it'll cycle
through the attributes that is it is
affecting so let's jump into another
game and those are those are only the
next fall the following the Box 5 yes
and then it'll go away and then may be
able to come back in a few games I
thought maybe you could sim further and
say ok now these 5 no I'd like as soon
as as soon as that scene kicks off it
starts right there
I need to hit a home run no yo I mean I
choose power bag like the names of the
stadiums for the the minor league teams
are they accurate well they're all
fictional all of our money we all are my
league stadiums are fictional and what
our art team does is they'll go around
to wherever they live or where they're
visiting and they'll just get ideas
thinking I should have swung at that yo
[Music]
and I'm also using one of the five new
batting cameras in the game is where I
think this is strike zone 3 its we're a
little lower rice yeah a little or got a
gallon second so that this is a batting
clutch based gain opportunity for me who
didn't get the call right base gains and
if you hold L to it you can switch the
camera when you're running like that
safe its power swung same clutch power
right window the full speed replay and
you hit Mark DeRosa and you can see all
of the 3d elements past the outfield
wall and again that goes back to what we
talked about earlier about the end of
minor league stadium all of the
backdrops have been worked on yeah it
seems like backdrops for these stadiums
I mean even backdrops for some of those
cutscenes so they're in the locker room
coach's office yeah we've done a lot of
work ball do you need my plate give him
a given give me my plate discipline now
you will you always get a plate
discipline if you take a ball yes you do
ok remember like these are small games
remember we're working on the in
side of one attribute point right
in-game that felt good that felt good I
thought I thought I I thought I got that
so nobody was on base though
yeah no way I was on base I got 50 power
me and I should be able to she'll be
able to do one there deep pop flies to
tell you that that's for 20 huh that's
long as long as those four it was like
398 there might have got out now right
now okay there we go let's just say so
if I do this right I should get a two
times boost or I'm gonna get the
opposite which won't be good Oh will it
yeah it'll be a two times let's go oh
and I got my sounds boost reaction to
our mag receipt and fielding so what
you're saying is that during two times
boost if you mess up that means you're
gonna get two times decrease any are you
okay
ooh that looks good get over his head
they don't want me they don't want me to
be great today that looked like I got
all of that 0 fault Lance felt good it's
all good if it was me and be a strikeout
strikeout groundout trying to do it and
see here we go going back to the base
gang screen and you can see
so there's your two times booth doesn't
know to time which was is there any way
to check how you're doing mid game yeah
just come here you can so you can see
the breakdown so this is basically every
pitch that I had I took that first ball
right plate distantly went up I got that
first hit power went up now if you do
something really really will you can't
fill out all three of these but you see
I only like for like a RBI a single you
only get going to get one but you can
max out all three of these and here we
can see exactly what happened right
remember a power song and I got a face
hit right and you see it animates it
shows it shows me how close I am my
batting clutch went up and we can see
the power going up so those are the base
gains that I got for the
one gang right and then we'll jump in
and there is no way for you to request a
specific focus training right no it's
completely there's no way for you to
request so you got to be strategic on
what you want to do but you get twenty
five of them per season when you get
that really really awesome one at the
end and obviously I need to hit a home
run
get to there we go it's a single with a
power swing and you don't need to use
power swing all the time that's just as
me that don't need to use it all the
time that's basically the attributes we
chose to we first time yeah because we
chose I think bat first and so like
power it's all about the power so I'm
gonna do contacts means I watch I hit a
home run with contacts I mean a regular
swing well hi there and contact versus
right with that but see my my guys
running it out all right two times boots
activated that's right so you have this
game and then what three more and add
slow down I got this and remember like I
said when I I came here came here the
first time they have hundreds of new
throws hundreds of new caches caches
hundreds and transition animations all
of the gains we've made in game playing
core gameplay you know hitting fielding
pitching catching and throwing all of
that stuff comes over to roll to the
show as well tough hackneyed attack so
nice take it let's go whoo let's go I'm
all surprised I need to get to those the
plus guy said man that should have been
summer code like we gotta talk if I
didn't get three yeah I didn't get three
base games for that we gotta talk we got
this two times two with the two towns
come on son whoo all right house preset
got me hyped up but hit their home run
but we got it I see it's the easy money
easy money easy money all America I'm
fielding two times boots activated let's
go
feeling good feeling good Nick feeling
good feeling good all I'm trying to do
is hustle and motivate Nick that's all
I'm trying to do
nice nice deep ball here it comes home
run calling it right here it's home
right
no I think I'm gonna get out I should
this one at the first pitch if you do it
I got happy gotta stay calm like a
baseball you got it you got to stay calm
and patience can't get too high can't
get too low I have that problem
on life not just sports really good I
had an opportunity to make a real dope
play there but I messed it up so we
haven't talked about pitching so there
are pitching art types as well so the
difference between when you're playing a
game as a pitcher and as a position
player as a position player the base
gains and performance games happen after
every single pitch as a pitcher it
happens after the a bet okay because
that would be a to many pitchers on the
zoom you know the way it might be it
might get a little you know tiresome
seeing it pop up every every other
position though applies the way we're
seen at yeah yeah the base games happen
every single pitch or as soon as the
field and play is over I if you want to
feel right
these days animations yeah we have tons
of new celebration animations and you
know for wrote through the show
I mean we've added hundreds of batting
stances hundreds of new batting stance
Corrections we have new pitching motions
we have like 12 new pitching motions we
have like ten new batting stances we've
added a lot more personality into the
game we have more generic mild home run
celebrations and we have some that are
just quite insane and crazy this update
like its role to the show it's your guy
if you want to choose any of those cramp
crazy animations you can or you can
choose to be a little bit more subdued
it's all up to you but there's so many
more animations to choose from in the
game so we're gonna return the clubhouse
take a look at this base gain screen and
migrate for roll to the show let's say
let's see how close ah attribute
increase alright so we went from 51 to
52 and armed accuracy and we went for 51
52 in the field and you can see in the
upward circle you can see we actually
went up a point contact we ain't gonna
talk about that it went down a little
bit
our contact went down a little bit and
here's our breakdown I swung at every
single pitch which I need to do and here
we can see the base gains and this is
these are all of the gains that I got in
that one game that we just played so
power for power verse righty assuming
next game you have a couple hits
probably a value of 250 double move up
to 51 and then we'll be looking inside a
another attribute point cool and so
we'll sim one more so even get one more
training session I actually well we
won't simple so we still have three
games active and here's one of the new
off the field scenes and environments
enroll today showed us you this is a bus
we also have a plane and that is let's
roll to the show or that's a snippet of
roll to the show which we'll be talking
more about on our livestream on Thursday
at 2 p.m. Pacific time cool well I'm
pretty excited I know you teased this
last time so we finally got it to like
get into the real details real details
no more microtransactions and rules to
the show you can still use you to your
sails but you'll still choose an art
type and now we create your
you gotta know through the show you're
choosing an archetype this is a type of
guy you want to become at the end and we
have those max attributes and those max
caps and we have those current caps we
showed you how to improve your guy we
showed you how to improve the caps and
again you can't make your guy all 99 all
training points allotment is gone
everything is auto spit you want to hit
for power you need to hit the power
singles won't do it you need doubles and
triples and home runs and that's rolled
to the show well my thanks to Ramone
obviously for coming in and sharing
everything and we'll see you guys next
time
and we'll see you on your streams and
all the things that you're doing updates
and we can't wait for launch so very
coming so March 27th but early access if
you preorder you can take part in our
first pitch early access weekend on the
23rd let's go get on it alright we'll
see you guys later